[Music]
welcome back river babes I hope you all
had a happy and healthy Thanksgiving for
those who are wondering what's going on
I'm a little sick right now but the show
must go on
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 408 chapter 65 in treatment
which was all about our favorite revered
aliens seeking some much-needed guidance
now I feel like this episode was
Riverdale's attempt at one big reset
button to try and take the storylines
that have been way far off the rails and
get them back on track will it work only
time will tell but for now I do
appreciate this episode for shedding
some light on the conversations about
mental health and I do think that it
highlighted some sensational acting in
the cast yes I'm talking about you
Madeline patch girl you were amazing
now obviously we've got a lot to discuss
and I cannot wait to go all over your
kisses and kisses in just a little bit
but let's quickly recap what happened in
the therapists chair in the blue and
gold breakdown okay
so first up we need to know that this
episode established two things number
one the creepy I'm filming your houses
mystery person is back in all their VCR
loving glory and yeah number two it's
early acceptance time for all those
college bound seniors and the need of
the guidance counselor miss berbils
now despite her bizarre name berbils
really helped to burst the bubble of all
the problems the kids in Riverdale were
having like many things in the cooper
household were back to normal and by
normal I mean Alice was invading Betty's
privacy and trying to control her life
so during their joint fair therapy
session they realized that Alice's
smothering is doomed to one simple fact
she loves Betty the most same Alice same
by the end of the episode Alice was
trying to respect Betty's boundaries and
even help to repay some of the tuition
money she gave away to the farm the job
Alice
next up when Archie sat down with Birbal
he blabbed about his late-night
vigilante runs and she suggested
something that we've known for years
Archie is addicted to looking for
trouble now as a way of protecting his
mama
Archie decided to move out of the house
and into the community center where he
now has a direct tip line alerting him
to all of Riverdale's darkest troubles
whether or not he's still going to be a
vigilante we don't know
meanwhile Dahlonega got into Harvard yay
but then she quickly realized that Hiram
was involved and that's world her good
mood so Birbal diagnosed that Veronica
doesn't actually hate her father no
she's obsessed with him and he's
obsessed with her cool so rather than
walking away from him for good which is
what I was hoping she would do she said
she was going to make a competing rum
company because that makes sense as for
Sheryl [ __ ] Cheryl had to sit there
while burble recapped all of the
horrible things that has happened to her
over these last few years but then she
really opened up about JJ Julianne and
to everything and Birbal helped Cheryl
realized that she's not crazy she's just
a girl who's missing her brother oh and
Cheryl also had a test done and realized
that she didn't absorb her brother
Julian instead the truth is that there's
someone in Sissel house playing tricks
on her with that doll no I know it's not
Tony
because Tony is an angel so Nana Rosen
had better not be you either lastly when
Jughead visited his old school for a
transcript Birbal lured him with candy
and got him to confess about the
conspiracy theories he's been working on
regarding the Baxter books she helped
him realize that he shouldn't be
idolizing his grandfather but instead
should be appreciating all that his own
father has done for him but just as jug
was getting back on track he realized
that many members of the quill and skull
Club were killed in tragic accidents aka
they were most likely murdered which
then led us to another flash-forward and
let Donna and Bret named Veronica Betty
and Archie as the ones who killed
Jughead Dunstan ton and actually I want
us to take another look at that flash
board scene in full let's watch it right
now shall we
are you sure these are the three
suspects you saw that night it's
definitely them those are the kids we
saw killed Jughead
not buying it I'm not buying it are you
guys buying it honestly if you really
think that FP is gonna believe Donna and
Brett over Betty Archie and Veronica
then you've got like another thing
coming I still love the theory out there
that this is scenes from the book that
jug is writing that's playing out that
we're seeing into some like book tastic
world that's what I'm going with because
none of this makes sense or that FP is
laying the trap to get Donna and Brett
to try and confess instead and that the
kids are in on it I don't know I don't
know all I know is
nice try Riverdale now normally at this
point we're gonna take a look at the
most romantic moments of the episode
with seven seconds in heaven but
honestly there weren't any yes there
were two really brief but cute scenes
with Shoni and bug-head but I'd much
rather focus our attention on what you
all thought of this episodes luck dive
into kisses and kisses all right guys
now first up I called out on Twitter
last night and asked you river babes to
vote in a poll as to which student you
think mrs. verbal helps the most and
here are the results so overwhelmingly
71% of you said that Cheryl got the most
benefit from these conversations which I
completely agree followed by Betty at
17% Archie at 7 and 4% of you named
others many of you were saying you saw
that Alice got the most from verbal but
yes Cheryl definitely was the one that I
think needed this the most and I think
that she benefited from it and I think
that verbal had a lot of really positive
things to say and I want to take a look
at what you guys were saying right now
so okay first up Victoria said Jughead
isn't dead not possible
completely agree Gerald Washington says
I'm glad another adult was introduced
who wasn't Shady but I'm surprised at
four seasons that they're only now
bringing in a therapist like I said I
think that this is a good opportunity
for Riverdale to use this new character
as a way to kind of get the kids back on
track I would like for us to see miss
Birbal again who else was surprised at
her name was Miss burble I assumed that
that was based off of an Archie comics
character
it's not that's just the name they chose
so you know what verbal welcome
I like your bubbles I don't know what
that meant so we're just gonna go with
it and move right on past okay cool
I'm taking a lot of cold medicine right
now so that's why I'm a little goofy
thanks guys
Paulina said hope you feel better soon
thanks Paulina appreciate it
Jessica O'Donnell said exactly Cheryl
did great Madeline Pech did fantastic in
this episode and Becky Foster in threes
she said Madeline Pech was incredible
with a heart and RIE Couser said kisses
to that Jones men hug that was so sweet
I loved that one a lot you guys also
sent in a lot of great tweets last night
and our first tweet is coming to us from
at Pech and that's a sign instead of an
S and said his sister the lack of Toni
in this episode I think it would have
been a great opportunity for the writers
to address her backstory kisses to
Cheryl finally talking about her mental
illness to someone who genuinely wants
to help it's refreshing
hashtag kisses and kisses I completely
agree that I would have loved to have
seen Toni also get a sit-down with Miss
Birbal as we know she's been living in
thistle house she's been going through
all of this with Cheryl and I feel like
it would have been great for us to be
able to get to see Toni talk a little
bit about the pressures that she's been
under not only being strong herself but
having to be strong for Cheryl and I
thought that was also another great
point that at Pech made saying that that
could have been a great way for us to
dive into Tony's backstory which
supposedly has come in the season now I
also think that Kevin could have really
benefited from a sit-down with the
guidance counselor as well because you
know he was brainwashed into a cult just
like Alice was so goodness gracious this
show and then also Reggie Reggie who's
been dealing with an abusive father and
trying to deal with the aftermath of
confronting him with that he would have
also benefited greatly as well obviously
having five of our students sit down
with them sit down with verbal took up a
lot of time so I understand the
timelines they can't have every single
person go into the therapists chair but
it's Riverdale they should have a weekly
therapy session they really should okay
more comments
from you guys because you guys are
flooding the inboxes right now okay
Catina zelkova said it kisses to Cheryl
for everything she's been through and
for responding to therapy like the
champion she is while being her sassy
unique self yes it was very
heartbreaking to see her lose control of
the Vixens but at the same time I
understand that that's like kind of what
Cheryl lived for because we haven't seen
a vixen seen in quite some time we
haven't seen any this season it was hard
for me to remember that that's something
that Cheryl cared passionately about you
guys let me know if you agree because of
the fact that we haven't seen we've only
seen Cheryl in Thistle house I'm not
quite sure I I missed that emotional
emotional connection miss friend's fan
forever I said can the guidance
counselor please stick around I love
that we finally got a new character
that's actually normal I mean I feel
like if she did stick around then she
wouldn't be normal because that's what
Riverdale does yeah yeah okay more
comments from you guys right now
Emily Roth Miller said Veronica Archie
should move in together at this point
sure sure
we're not yeah I would love Veronica to
get out of her house that would be great
and actually that leads us to another
tweet right now from at gummy bear pizza
and they wrote hashtag kisses to Betty
for doing that amazing Alice impression
Elizabeth and hisses to the counselor
for not realizing that Cheryl literally
talks to a taxidermied human body also
hisses to the launch family drama cuz
it's just an endless loop
yes I'm so glad you said this truly oh I
was really hoping that this was the
episode that we were gonna say goodbye
to Hiram because having the guidance
counselor go off on that weird dream
Greek tragedy storyline sure but tell
Veronica like you're obsessed with your
father he's obsessed with you I was
hoping that she would finally that cool
I need to sever ties and not be near him
at all and instead
yes Veronica can do no wrong and of
course she's does amazing and everything
she does but now she's gonna start a rum
wine it's not even a line I'm thinking
like
fashion line a rum distillery sure like
I love Veronica so much but I'm just I
would like to see her just not have a
storyline that has to do with Hiram let
her do something else I just like you
said it's always a loop and I'm just
ready for us to just break the loop yeah
no no no okay we have Megan violence and
she's a hisses to the fact that they
think they can solve all of these kids
problem in one episode with one therapy
session Aarthi Liam here we are coming
from at least one therapy session is
better than no therapy session you know
and I do think like I said at the
beginning of this episode it's good that
it's shining light on mental health and
it's okay to talk about things when
you're not feeling okay it's okay to
talk to someone there that we shouldn't
have the stigma in it and that you
should be able to open up and be brave
enough to say you know what I would
really benefit from talking this out
with with a professional and I think
that that's a great step that Riverdale
did but yes I agree it's I'm not sure
Nika Nika Cuomo said is this to Hiram
for being Hyrum and kisses to juggy for
hugging f.p it was so cute I watched it
over and over again oh it was so cute
but I did find it a little bizarre that
seemed cut from jugg hugging FP in the
living room and then the next scene was
Betty walking past the living room to go
talk to Alice like they want us to
forget that that's not the same house
but it is also are we calling it the
Cooper Jones house al said her name's L
Smith what are we calling it just the
house where everyone lives should Archie
move in there should baraka move in
there should we just start like a big
frat house I don't know we need more
sets
Kevin see I bet Brett and Donna killed
him right and Donna would love to kill
Jughead I'm sure they're psychotic so
I'm sure that's something that's
happening
Darryl Washington said that scene from
the book theory is so valid I'll be
surprised if they don't do it right it
makes sense it's a good way to like kind
of explain it all
Catherine Horton says can we please get
an explanation on the Cooper Jones home
because I'm so confused with it well
Oh Catherine what up through ya I feel
ya
Emily rothmiller said Veronica and
arches movin together yes Amy we said
hisses - Archie leaving his mom to
protect random people yes
Archie I don't know what to do anymore
and like I said I will give Archie the
benefit of the doubt for the rest of the
season because he's been through a lot
but he's got a heart of gold and that's
all that's leading him through I think
he's thinking with his heart and not
with his brain so let's take a look at
another tweet we have one from at River
X nugget and they said kisses to Betty
for being all sassy and honest loves the
quote at least they were physical fizzle
rocks not birth control because God
forbid once again Lilly Reinhardt just
firing on all cylinders I love the way
that she plays Betty especially when she
gets to be all sassy but I also loved
how in that confrontation when Alice
found Betty's birth control she yelled
to her she was like you are out of
control
yeah and I wanted to just scream back to
Alice actually she's very much in
control Alice had the birth control hmm
and Alice got pregnant at 17 Polly got
pregnant at 16 I think that Betty's
being very smart she's very smart girl
also gigantic plot hole we need to
address right now Cheryl's been
babysitting the twins if Alice has that
much time on her hands she should take
the twins I know that Polly is
apparently not her favorite child but
she loves those twins at the beginning
when they're floating so honestly why
does she not have the twins that is my
biggest issue at this point with
Riverdale yeah I will die on that he'll
give the twins to Alice put the twin
somewhere stop giving them Cheryl are
the twins okay
pretty sure Dana Rose can't take care of
the twins this is just this we're at you
guys this is where we're at okay unique
here and eek
hey girl said I don't know how I feel
about Alice favoriting a child over the
other but I'm glad she embed
or reconciling I mean obviously as a
parent they say you're not supposed to
have a favorite child
you know I'm not a mom so I can't speak
in personal experience but I can say I'm
one of four siblings my mom totally has
a favorite not me she loves me it's
horrible but everyone I'm sure they go
through phases like you like the one
who's closest to you I don't know okay
nikka Guam Oh said kisses to Cheryl for
finally interacting with the world right
Cheryl went to Pop's you guys
she went out of fiscal house she went to
school thirty-six absences though that
what they said 36 it's so much school
that you've missed how what time I guess
it's I'm trying to think back to high
school if it was early acceptance
it's like December I think I don't know
Rebecca Epps said this is to the fact
that Kevin didn't get a therapy session
like what the hell he really needs it
they all need it man they all need it
but once again I truly and that a loss
for the fact that we have not had enough
Kevin and Tony specifically and at this
point every time I feel like I we should
come up with like a PG Riverdale like
drinking game like takes up your
milkshake every time Tony just says babe
and like I love that it's like a term of
endearment but like it always follows
like something we're like Cheryl says
something completely outrageous and
Tony's just like hey babe
like I I just need more I need more
Vanessa Morgan I need more Casey caught
and sure I'll take more Charles Milton
remember last year they did like the
other core for episode I hope we got
another one of those I hope we just get
a specific Tony episode of specific
Kevin episode but that can hold my
breath yeah
Tessa Wong says feel better LeeAnn
kisses to you thanks guys I'm so sorry
that I sound all stuffed up like this I
feel kind of I'm glad to be back here
with you and taya clay says I love your
turtleneck that's your color
yeah I'm selling this green moment today
you know the holidays are coming up I
hope you guys are all enjoying this
festive time and I hope none of you guys
are sick and then we've got another
tweet right now that's gonna be coming
to us from Atmaram our Laurie and she
said hisses for alice's easy Redemption
loving Betty the most know not how that
works if that's how she treats the child
she loves the most
I don't want to see what she did to the
one she hates giving her money back and
gluing the envelope back together it
won't fix the damage she's done either
hmm that's my question
did she glue back the Yale envelope or
was that a different schools envelope I
didn't look too closely I just saw the
check I saw money that was a bummer
though that it seems like that he didn't
get into Yale but that Veronica accepted
that she's going to Yale
maybe Betty will end up going to
wherever Jughead goes if he ever
actually applies I don't know
well they actually leave the town who
knows which leads me to my next point
which is I've been saving this for a
while I know I'd told you guys a couple
weeks ago that I was going to be giving
you an exclusive interview with the core
for revealing how much longer they think
that Riverdale will go on but then I
decided to save it because I was gonna
be better for the mid-season finale so
I'm sorry but that means that you're
gonna be getting it next week and that
means that I have KJ Lilly cami and Cole
answer a question where I said how much
longer do you envision Riverdale going
on and what do you think is gonna happen
and all their answers are so different
and so unique and I think that you guys
are really gonna like to see what they
have to say so tune in for that and you
know what we're done we're gonna leave
it there now thank you all so much for
tuning in to this week's Sweetwater
secrets and be sure to join me for a
next week's episode for 4:09 chapter 66
tangerine aka the mid-season finale of
Riverdale yes that's right we are here
but first give this video a like and
then tweet me your thoughts or comment
below with what you think is gonna
happen in the winter finale I cannot
believe that it's already the winter
finale also do you think that Kevin
Reggie and Tony should have all had
their own therapy sessions what did you
really think of this episode shout it
out in the comments below tell me and
everything and I'll see you next time
kisses to you bye
[Music]
you